this morning on the dish we head into
the kitchen with tyler aiken native of
wilmington delaware who's come home
after running
and opening nationally recognized
restaurants in washington in
philadelphia
he's putting a 21st century twist on a
historic landmark
and he's also keeping a table open for
another well-known wilmington native
president-elect joe biden
tyler aiken first stepped foot in the
green room at the historic hotel dupont
as a kid growing up in wilmington
delaware
this was the restaurant when you're
eight years old that you kind of didn't
want to go to
because you had to put on a blazer and
it was like classical music
but even then he could tell it was
something special
the space especially as a kid is so vast
you know and the the details so ornate
when i thought about
would i ever do a restaurant in delaware
i always had this
dream in my head that it would be this
restaurant
now he's the owner and head chef of la
cavier at the green room
transformed into a french brasserie what
akin didn't plan for
was opening a new restaurant in the
middle of a global pandemic
while running three more in nearby
philadelphia
two of them remain open but one recently
closed
we're all in the same boat as
restauranteurs it's just trying to
pivot adapt and survive at this point
he's channeling his concerns about the
pandemic into the independent
restaurants coalition
a group launched this year to represent
the roughly 500 000
independent restaurants nationwide
employing more than 11 million people
the group is led by well-known chefs
including jose andres
tom colicchio and thomas keller some of
these guys that you've partnered with
are people you've worked with before
competitors
probably people you want to emulate you
know some of my heroes
are on a zoom screen in front of me
every single day
all of the kind of star struck
aspect of it just melts away really
quickly because we're all there to
to get business done and what does
washington need to do
to help your industry quite simply they
need to pass the restaurants act
the legislation is passed in the house
but not the senate
it would provide about 120 billion
dollars in federal grants to restaurants
bars and other food companies
that had business dry up nearly
overnight once the pandemic
struck so many restaurants are closing
every day
and will have closed by the time this
thing has finally passed what happens to
a
community when the restaurant closes we
are entertainment
at the end of the day as much as we are
sustenance and
we stand to lose that
very important part of our local
cultures more importantly
we stand to lose jobs inspired by his
father aiken has been into politics
since he was a kid
and initially went to law school before
realizing he wanted to be a chef
he enrolled in the prestigious academia
cuisine
in washington so what do we have we've
got gnocchi parisian
french style gnocchi no potato involved
jumbo lump crab from the chesapeake
and then we gild the lily a little bit
with some uh with some caviar
that sounds amazing and then there's
cake french apple cider cake we make it
with like a farmhouse
northern french alcohol exciter a
uh galvados creme glaze and then if
calvados caramel pecans on there
aiken has worked in renowned kitchens
inspired by mediterranean and thai
flavors like comey and little cerro in
dc
and by israel like zahav in philadelphia
how do you get from all that to a french
brasserie
my dad's side is very french i wanted to
find
new ways to approach this cuisine that
drew from
my own personal history why do you try
to draw
influences from all those stops i've
made along the way take the collier's
grilled swordfish which is served with
whipped fenna
and a tzatziki made with butternut
squash
the whipped feta is something that you
know is a comey thing for sure
doing something like putting squash in
the tzatziki is
something that like reminds me of a lot
of the stuff we did at tahoe it was
often taking a traditional thing
like ted ziki and like doing it a little
differently he's also updated the
historic space
all these memories in this restaurant we
needed to honor people who've
gotten engaged here celebrated
anniversaries birthdays
it was like a balancing act between
updating it
making it commercially viable but also
preserving the integrity of the
restaurant keeping it recognizable
built in 1913 the hotel dupont has
hosted presidents
movie stars and world leaders co-owner
rob buccini and his firm
bought the property in 2013 from the
dupont chemical company
it's been the anchor of a nearly 2
billion dollar redevelopment of downtown
and of joe biden's political life
but you don't think of yourself as
anything other than the story when you
come in here
it's been you know part of delaware
history and
obviously part of the the biden history
as well for a lot of people
it is the hotel dupont but it's also the
biden hotel it's that place where he
always seems to do
big things yes in 1972 then 29 year old
joe biden celebrated his first
senate election night victory there more
recently the ballrooms were settings for
speeches
and campaign produced videos buccini is
hoping that the hotel's presidential
connection
helps once the pandemic ends we think
that the biden effect will be
significant
that people will come to visit
wilmington
find out how great a place it is the
newly reopened restaurant has yet to get
a visit from wilmington's most famous
resident
thanks to the pandemic has he been here
yet we expect to see him
but you hold the table for him
absolutely
yum we wish you brought the cake i know
so you take the
seller down to wilmington i'll take this
from dc
we'll meet there by the way real quick
have you ever had street closures for
your dish
no you had we had the street closed so
that we could do that outside so special
thanks to the wilmington police
department